- [Presenter] This 128
foot long super yacht
runs almost $14 million to purchase,
but that's just the
beginning of its expenses.
- [James] It's a city, it's
a resort, and it moves.
- [Presenter] But imagine
if that resort sat on top
of one of the planet's
saltiest, wettest environments.
Yacht owners can also expect to pay
10 to 20% of the yachts value each year
simply to maintain it.
Superyachts or yachts longer than 82 feet
can sell for hundreds
of millions of dollars.
This means maintenance could
be tens of millions per year.
Here's what goes into this superyacht's
estimated annual budget
of nearly 1.9 million.
- [James] Welcome aboard Snowbird.
- [Presenter] Cost that up
even before owner set sail.
- [James] Dockage fees are very expensive.
They range from $3.50 a
foot to 7.50 a foot per day.
- [Presenter] Dockage fees
can be so high for superyachts
in part because there's a large demand
for a limited number of spaces,
but if owners keep their yachts docked,
they could face other
large maintenance expenses.
- All the works of the
bottom of the vessel
gets scummed up with oysters
and clams and barnacles.
A lot of these electronics,
they get fouled up if they
sit dormant for a long time.
It's definitely better to
use it than let it sit.
- [Presenter] While docked,
the yacht can connect to
the Marina's power grid
for basic operations,
but when it's out at sea, this
368 ton vessel requires fuel,
a lot of it.
- For someone like myself,
I call this boat yoga.
What we have here is the day tank.
This holds approximately
800 gallons of fuel.
See the red?
That's the amount that's in the tank.
- [Presenter] In total,
this yacht can hold almost
12,000 gallons of fuel.
Plus, other water
vehicles like its jet skis
and support boat will need even more gas.
- Generally, we burn anywhere
from 60 gallons an hour
to 120 gallons an hour.
- [Presenter] At around four
and a half dollars a gallon.
- [James] It costs
approximately $360,000 per year
to fuel Snowbird.
- [Presenter] But day-to-day maintenance
is actually the fourth
largest operating cost
and it can get messy.
- Today we're gonna be changing out
the crankcase ventilation filter.
That keeps your turbos
and your after cooler
from getting gummed up,
and it also helps reduce oil consumption
and reduce air pollution
by further combustion inside the engine.
This part probably costs
$60, $70 to replace,
but it has immeasurable value
in prolonging the
longevity of your motors.
Maintaining the engines
on a yacht like Snowbird
typically costs around $60,000 a year,
and you're looking at parts, time,
and the materials involved
to change the oils
and keep everything up and going.
- [Presenter] That's just below deck.
Superyacht owners also need to invest
in keeping the rest of the
yacht in pristine condition,
like the teak flooring.
Teak is typically used on yachts
because it's a weather
resistant luxury material,
but it's also challenging to maintain.
- [Josh] When we scrub the teak,
oftentimes it only lasts
roughly a week or two
depending on the traffic on board.
It wants to go back to its natural color,
and, you know, between
rain and rinsing it down,
you kinda wash away all of that,
you know, hard work that you've done.
Annually the teak flooring
costs about $18,000 to maintain.
- [Presenter] Adding on smaller expenses,
you're already looking
at just over $1 million.
But by far, there's one cost
for maintaining superyachts
that completely surpasses
the others, the crew.
The estimated budget for Snowbird's crew
is over $800,000 per year and
that's because super yachts
must always have a crew even when docked.
- You have to take care of the teak
the paint, wash windows, machinery.
Rust never sleeps,
maintenance never stops.
- [Presenter] Cost towards
their health insurance,
travel expenses, uniforms,
and cell phone bills
can add thousands to the budget.
Adding in crew expenses
brings the annual operating cost estimate
to nearly 1.9 million a year,
but that's only when
there are no major repairs
or maintenance
while owners generally
spend around 10% a year
in maintenance costs for new superyachts.
- [James] It's kind of a guideline,
but as she gets three years or five years,
or hits her 10 year, it's
gonna be more than 10%.
- [Presenter] Every five years or so,
superyacht owners have to shell out
for one of their largest expenses.
- Paint jobs are sometimes
from a hundred thousand
to a million bucks, depending
on your size of your boat.
Paint is about $1,800 an inch,
- [Presenter] Salt in the water and air
corrodes the yachts paint.
To repaint the entire yacht,
it needs to be hauled out of the water,
then it can take months to
complete a fresh paint job.
There are also other
major potential expenses.
Some yacht owners need to spend
hundreds of thousands of
dollars every few years
on detailed inspections.
And if a yacht fails in inspection,
repairing or replacing it
could run $200,000 or more.
- Certain boats, you
can't get the engines out.
You have to cut a hole in the side
and then reweld it, recertify the hole.
Now you're into the multi-millions
to change out an engine.
- [Presenter] To recoup
some of these costs,
superyacht owners will
rent out their vessels.
The charter fee for this super yacht
ranges from $125 to $145,000 per week,
that covers the boat and the crew,
but renters also need to
pay for additional expenses
like fuel, food, and customs fees.
Plus, there's a customary tip
of 18 to 25% for the crew members.
At best, superyacht owners
might break-even on maintenance costs
with income earned from chartering.
- I don't think it's a
profitable situation.
At best, they're covering their salaries
and the boat's way as it travels.
Wear and tear is always there
and the money would have
to go back into the vessel.
If you didn't properly
maintain your vessel,
your value would decrease.
Most people that buy yachts
of this size and this stature
really wanna take care of them.
(upbeat music)